mon frigo se brise je poursuis qui celui
qui m'a vendu le frigo ou celui qui l'a
fabriqué la question est facile à
trancher
pendant que la garantie du fabricant est
encore valide on vous conseille de faire
vos réclamations auprès de lui mais ces
garanties s'envolent rapidement
heureusement la garantie légale prendre
le relais quelle est la durée de cette
garantie légale nous avons fouiner dans
25 jugement de petites créances qui
établissent ce qui est raisonnable pour
les frigos lave-vaisselle laveuse
sécheuse et cuisinières et pendant cette
période si votre appareil se brise qui
est responsable
le détaillant ou le fabricant réponse
les deux les deux sont responsables de
réparer remplacer ou remboursé en tout
ou en partie et la garantie légale
appelé aussi garantie implicite dans
certaines provinces existe dans tout le
canada
rappelez-vous détaillants et fabricants
forme duo inséparable par ces mots
[Musique]